[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN:
I'm with Firebase
and I've been at
Google for two years.
And this is my third
time being at Next.
I remember the first
time I was there.
It was almost two years ago,
just a few blocks from here.
I see someone
nodding over there.
It was in the Warfield
Theater at Market Street.
Who else was there?
OK, just a few people.
And actually,
that's how it feels.
To me, that was my first
big Google conference,
and I was really, to
be honest, intimidated
with the number of people there.
And now it's two years later
and there's over 10,000 of us
here at Moscone.
It's grown so much.
As we say at Google, it's
growing at the speed of clouds.
I remember when we launched
App Engine back in 2008.
It was the first tool
of what would later
become Google Cloud Platform.
But to be honest, for us
it was just a new thing
that we wanted to
release out there.
And now, less than 10 years
later, we have over 150 APIs
that you can use in the
Google Cloud Platform.
It's grown at a tremendous rate.
That's a thing that you
constantly see in technology.
Not only do things
keep getting better,
they get better
faster and faster.
I'd like to take you back on a
bit of a journey back in time.
So we founded Google
almost 20 years ago.
And our mission was to organize
the world's information
and to make it universally
accessible and useful.
And that's still
our mission today,
but that's pretty
much the only thing
that has remained constant.
The technology that we have
available to reach that mission
has grown so much
since 20 years ago.
Think of it.
It was essentially the early
days of the public internet.
Since we're traveling
back in time,
I always think back of
when I got my first PC.
It was just under 30 years ago.
And it was sort of a hideous
box that you would rather
put on the far corner of your
desk, or even better, under it.
But it was my personal computer.
It had a whopping 20
megabyte hard drive.
And that made me one
of the lucky ones,
because hard drives were not
very common 30 years ago.
It had, let's see, one
megabyte of memory.
And that was a lot back then.
But if you now look at
your phone or your laptop,
you probably have eight gigs or
maybe even 16 gigs of memory.
So that's 8,000 times
or 16,000 times more
in less than 30 years.
Moore's law has
been working hard
for us in the past decades.
And my PC ran at 60
megahertz, and that was a lot.
And it made me feel
like a magician,
because here was a
computer on my desk
that I could make do
whatever I wanted.
I came up with a
thing in my mind,
and I would translate
it into codes,
and then the PC would do
exactly what I wanted.
Or maybe not really
exactly what I wanted,
it mostly would do
exactly what I told it,
but still it was pretty good.
And it's a magical moment,
because no generation
before ours had
wielded so much power
over such powerful technology.
It was like magic.
That brings me to one
of my favorite quotes,
which is, "Any sufficiently
advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic."
It's from a science fiction
author, Arthur C. Clarke.
And it ties two of my
favorite topics together.
Technology-- that's
why I'm here on stage--
and science fiction, because
like many geeks, I love sci-fi.
I love sci-fi for many reasons.
They are often inspired
stories, but also they
seem to inspire
technology quite often.
For example, if you think
back of the original Star Trek
series, it was launched in
the mid '60s on network TV.
And the crew had to
communicate with each other.
And they did that using devices
that they called communicators.
And this is 50 years
ago, so clearly that
didn't exist back then.
So the writers of this
show were in a room
and they had to make up the
thing that would allow the crew
to communicate.
So they wrote in the script,
they're using communicators.
And then the props team would
look at that and is like OK.
So we take a piece of
wood, and we paint it,
and that's how we communicate.
The technology
didn't exist then.
But if you fast
forward 30 years,
you see that actually the mobile
phones became commonplace.
And people across
the entire world
could communicate with
their mobile phones.
And not surprisingly,
if you look
at the first mobile phones,
they looked somewhat
like Star Trek communicators.
Like if you have ever
had a Motorola StarTAC,
it was clearly the
same type of design.
You can see how technology
takes inspiration
from science fiction.
I always had to
laugh at the Picard.
If he wanted a drink, he would
say, "Computer, Tea, Earl Grey,
Hot."
And it would materialize there.
He probably said it with a
slightly more British accent
than I can put up here.
Now we don't have the
materialization technology yet,
not even us at Google.
But I'm quite sure somebody
somewhere is working on that.
But voice recognition?
I think we've done a bit better
than they did in the series,
because if you now use your
Google Home or your Assistant,
you can talk to it
and give instructions
that are a lot more complex
than what Picard used to do.
And it will understand
you perfectly.
But one thing about sci-fi I
always find most fascinating
is when they would send
the team to the planet.
And they roughly had three types
of scenarios that could happen.
The first scenario is that the
planet was completely empty.
And that typically meant
that the planet was
about to explode, or
the sun in the system
was about to go supernova
and they had about 40 minutes
to get out of there.
Second option was that
the planet was inhabited
by non-humanoid creatures.
And those non-humanoid
creatures would then not
speak any language that the
crew could have comprehended.
So the entire episode was about
finding a way to communicate.
And those were some of
my favorite episodes,
because I love
communication problems.
But the third type of episode
and by far the most common one
was that they would
beam down to the planet,
they would find
humanoid creatures,
and those humanoid
creatures would all
speak perfect English.
I'm not sure.
But I don't fully
get how that works,
because I live on
one planet, and not
everyone speaks English.
How do we have a
galaxy that's filled
with many different races and
they speak perfect English?
I don't think it's realistic.
But what annoyed
me is, they also
never gave an explanation
for how this works.
And language, for me,
is a fascinating topic.
Because I often think
that it's the next barrier
that we're trying
to break through.
For example, if you
have Google Translate,
you travel to a
country where they
speak a different language,
you see something on the menu,
you take out your phone, you
type the word on the menu,
and you see what
you want to order.
Or maybe if there's a sign,
you point your camera to it,
Google Translate
will show the sign
in the language you understand.
And that's technology we've been
working at for a few decades.
It's pretty good.
But about two or
three years ago,
I saw that there were
releases of video conferencing
software that would do
live translation of speech.
So there was a
video release where
you saw a class of
school kids in the US.
They were sitting
in front of a PC.
And on the other
end of the PC, there
was a class of school kids
somewhere else in the world--
let's say in Spain--
and the kids in the US would
say something in English.
And the kids in Spain would hear
that same sentence in Spanish.
And the kids in
Spain would respond,
and the English kids would hear
the same sentence in English.
And I was like, this is magic.
This is the future
of communication.
But as I just said,
if it's like magic,
then it's probably just a
very advanced technology.
I also thought, wait.
I didn't see this in Star Trek.
But I saw this earlier.
I read about it somewhere.
Because like any good geek,
I read The Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy by Douglas Adams.
And he had a good
explanation of why everyone
could talk to each other.
Because he said,
everyone, at birth,
is implanted in their ear with
a tiny creature called a Babel
fish.
And a Babel fish will take
whatever language is coming in.
It will make it into the
language that they understand.
That's how everyone
could communicate
in the entire galaxy.
I'm like, ah, this
is Babel fish.
I get it.
But it's been two
and a half years,
and I still don't have
this implanted in my ear.
And now if you saw the
keynote this morning,
Urs had a tiny chip.
But I didn't get access
to that one in time.
So what I think
is realistic today
is that we actually
turn this into an app.
So I want to have
an app on my phone
where I have a dial that
makes me select the language.
And that's the language that
I speak and that I understand.
And then somebody else, say
in Japan, also has that app.
And they select their language,
and that's the language
that they will hear that
they will speak to me.
This is sort of what they
did in the school class,
and what Douglas Adams
predicted, but then something
that we could do
today, probably.
And when I say today
I really mean today.
Because I'm checking
the counter here--
we have a good half hour left.
We are Cloud Next.
I just said that we're going
to pick the pace up a bit.
So I think we can totally build
this app today here on stage.
Thing is, I say we,
because I definitely
know that I can't build
this one on my own.
So that's why I invited
a few of my friends
to help me out here on stage.
Mike, Jen, let's build an app.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE MCDONALD: Thanks, Frank.
Does anyone here have a
boss who stands on stage
and pitches for 15
minutes this magical idea,
and then hands you a microphone
and says, go build it
in the next half hour?
I see a couple of hands.
Yeah.
That's what we're
doing right now.
So if you didn't come
to this presentation,
you might start thinking, this
is how we need to build an app.
We have our mobile
applications that
make RESTful calls to
some application server.
So that could be
Java or PHP or Ruby.
And then that application
server handles
all of the complex
application logic.
That's going to handle
our authentication
and authorization.
That's going to handle
all the translation, all
of the storing of the files.
And it's going to ship it
out to the other cloud API,
so the cloud databases
and cloud storage examples
that store all of that.
But the counter says 46
minutes and 27 seconds.
As easy as it is to
spin up VMs, that
would still take us too long.
We would be provisioning
all of our servers.
Are we going to secure them
in the next 45 minutes?
Like, that's going to
be a really, really
difficult problem.
We need to move really
quickly to build this app
to meet Frank's specs.
Luckily, you all
came to this talk.
And you're going to learn the
secret to build applications
incredibly quickly.
And that secret
is using Firebase.
With Firebase,
our mobile clients
talk directly to powerful,
managed infrastructure,
like a database and an
object storage solution.
This means that
your apps don't have
to go through that middle
tier and can speak directly
to those different APIs.
In case you were asleep
during the keynote
and didn't know
what Firebase was,
Firebase is a full
application platform.
It is Google's mobile platform.
It allows you to develop
your applications
on top of Google Cloud
Platform, grow your user base,
and monetize and
earn more money.
Because this is a
develop talk, we're
going to focus just
on a couple of those
develop features
that will help build
our app as quickly as possible.
First, a cloud storage solution
that lets you upload and share
exabytes-- literally exabytes--
of user data.
Combine that with a serverless
authentication system that
handles complex authentication
flows and session management
with ease.
And lastly, a real time database
that stores and synchronizes
JSON data in milliseconds.
Let's start first
with cloud storage.
Frank said that he wants to talk
into his phone and upload that
file to share with everyone.
Cloud storage is Google's
way of storing up
to five terabyte objects.
And obviously, our audio files
are not going to be that large.
But it's good to have that kind
of scale behind the scenes.
We can use the Firebase
SDKs for cloud storage
to take a file that we
record on our device
and robustly upload
it to the cloud.
And by robust, how
many of you guys
are enjoying the
conference Wi-Fi?
It's a little flaky, right?
What about mobile networks?
I commute in on a
train every day,
and I'm in a tunnel
for four minutes.
I want to keep using my app.
And if I start uploading,
I want to make sure
that that file
gets to the cloud.
The Firebase SDKs for cloud
storage handle that seamlessly.
We have SDKs for Android, iOS,
JavaScript, c++, and Unity.
So we can meet your application
needs wherever they are.
And it's all serverless.
You don't have to spin up any
servers to proxy authentication
or get signed URLs
to upload from.
You can upload directly
to the cloud, securely.
And when the time comes
to download and share
that content, it's all coming
over Google's incredibly
awesome world scale network.
I promise, things
download really quickly.
They're often edge cached.
And it can instantly
be transmitted out
to hundreds, thousands,
or hundreds of thousands
of devices.
But what about security?
Can anyone just upload a file?
We don't want-- we want
these two lovely folks
and we want all of you
to be able to upload
and download our files.
But we don't want people outside
or people to upload nefarious
things.
We need to secure that.
And we can do that with
Firebase authentication.
With Firebase authentication,
you can log in your users
using any of a number of
common social providers--
Google, Facebook, Twitter,
GitHub, your own custom email
password solution,
or we even have
integrations to do your
own custom authentication.
So if you have SAML or
an existing SSO provider,
you can use that
directly with Firebase.
Again, this is
completely serverless.
You aren't spinning up
your own OAuth flows.
Have people done OAuth flows?
Couple people.
Have people done SAML?
That's also really painful.
Yeah.
Bunch of people
raise their hand?
Yeah.
We handle all of those things.
And it's really, really easy.
No servers, no other three
legged OAuth flows or OAuth
redirects.
You just use our SDKs directly
from those client libraries
and log your users in.
The other really cool thing
about Firebase authentication
is under the hood we
federate all those users.
So even if a user comes
in via Facebook or Google,
we can create a
single user account
and link across all of those.
This is especially cool for
anonymous authentication.
So if you have an
e-commerce site,
and you want users to add
items to their shopping cart,
you don't have to force
them to log in initially.
But when they check out, and
you prompt them to log in,
you can seamlessly link
that anonymous account
with one of these
social providers,
and carry all of
their items over.
Again, without having to
prompt them to do this.
It's really, really impressive.
So now we're able
to upload our files
and download our files securely.
But we need to synchronize
that file information
across all of our phones.
And for that, we have the
Firebase Realtime Database.
The Firebase Realtime Database
was Firebase's first product.
And it was kind of magical,
and you'll see why in a minute.
The Firebase Realtime Database
is a NoSQL JSON database.
It looks kind of
something like this.
It's just a big blob
of JSON in the sky--
synchronizes across all
of your client devices.
In our case, we're going
to be storing information
about uploads--
a language code, and
a link to the file
that's stored in cloud storage.
Now when you use
traditional databases,
typically they follow a
request-response paradigm.
So I would have to pull
my database every five
seconds or every minute and say,
hey, is there a new audio file?
I'm listening for things.
Please update me.
The Firebase Realtime Database
doesn't work like that.
We don't want your
mobile applications
pulling every five seconds and
burning through battery life.
We want to tell you as a
developer and let you say,
hey, Firebase, let me
know when data changes.
And when any of those clients
makes a change in the database,
we can push that data out to all
of the devices in milliseconds.
It's really impressive.
You'll see it here in a minute.
But listening to me
talk is not going
to help Frank build his app.
We need to switch
over to code and see
what it's like to
actually build this app.
Over on my right,
so everyone's left,
Frank is building an iOS app.
And over on my left,
your right, Jenny
is building an Android app.
And let's pop over
to the emulators
now that they're warm.
And you can see the bare
structure of our application.
We have a sign in, sign
out button up at the top.
We have a language
picker that lets
you select what language you
want to hear the recordings in.
We have a big
"record" button that
lets you record and
then stop recording,
and a text field that
shows the translated text.
And what's going to happen with
this application is once they
click "record", the app will get
an audio file on its local disk
that we can upload
to cloud storage.
And then eventually, it
will get a notification
from the database that gives a
little bit of translated text
that will populate.
So let's start filling
in the guts of that.
We've already added Firebase
through CocoaPods and Gradle
to our apps and
configured it to be ready.
So the first thing
that we want to do
is, within our application,
create instances
of storage, authentication, and
the Firebase Realtime Database.
Super easy to go
ahead and do that.
The next thing that we're going
to do is start our file upload.
So as I said, once you
push that record button,
we'll hand this function a file.
And we're going to create a
reference in cloud storage
where we want to
store that file.
We'll also add some
information about the file.
In this case, we're going
to include the content type,
so the eventual APIs
know how to process that.
And then, using
one line of code,
we're going to upload
this to cloud storage.
It is quite literally this easy.
You just say what
file, hand it the file,
and we can upload it robustly.
We also want to
know what happens
when that file is uploaded.
So we're going to add listeners
for failure and success.
On failure, we'll pop
up a little toast that
says, hey, the upload failed.
You should probably
try something else.
And on success, we'll
write that metadata
to the real time database
so we can synchronize it.
You ready to try this out?
OK.
Let's run the apps and
try uploading something.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: Hello world.
Famous first words.
MIKE MCDONALD: Oh.
Oh, what happened?
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN:
Oh, did it work?
MIKE MCDONALD: No, I
don't think it worked.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN:
Does yours work?
JEN TONG: Hello world.
MIKE MCDONALD: Aw, sad face.
The upload failed.
Well, you know why it failed?
Because we don't want to
allow anyone to upload files.
Cloud storage is
secured by default.
We need to add Firebase
authentication to authenticate
Frank and Jenny and
make sure that they only
are allowed to upload files.
So, going back up to the top,
we have that Auth get instance.
We're going to first add a
little bit of business logic,
to check if we have a
user currently logged in.
And after that, we're going
to cheat here a little,
because we have 36
minutes remaining.
Authentication is really
hard, and it's really critical
to get right.
So Firebase has provided
a set of libraries
called Firebase UI that provide
whole social Auth flows.
So we can import that
library, set it up,
and say that we want to
use email as well as Google
as authentication providers.
And then what's going
to happen with that--
if the user is not
logged in, we'll
pop up that authentication
flow, and walk them
through a whole UI flow
to authenticate them.
Otherwise, we'll start listening
for translations coming in
from the database.
Let's try that again, guys.
JEN TONG: Yes.
MIKE MCDONALD: There we go,
the screen just popped up,
Frank is going to click on
Sign In with Google, sign
in with his chosen demo Google
account, and here we are.
Let's try uploading again.
- Hello world.
JEN TONG: Hello world.
MIKE MCDONALD: There we go.
So we saw the toast
that said uploaded.
Let's go to the
Firebase console.
And again, we don't want to
pull a cover over your eyes.
We want to show you that
file within our cloud storage
bucket.
So here, you can see one file,
the audio AMR from Android
and the LINEAR16 file from iOS.
Oh, that was pretty
magical, right?
Let's also hop
over the database,
just to make sure that
we're synchronizing
our metadata to the
Realtime Database as well.
And there you can go.
You can see two files with
a bunch of file metadata
about Firebase.
Again, so that was what?
15 lines of code?
20 lines of code?
Something like that.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
OK.
So we have files uploading.
We're doing it securely.
Now we want to know any
time a new file is added.
We're going to listen
for a translation.
And for that, we're going to use
the Firebase Realtime Database.
So we're going to create another
reference to our database
and we're going to listen
for translations to come in.
Here, we're going to call
this a child added event that
says, any time a new
translation comes in, notify me
of that translation.
And once we have
that translation,
we'll add yet another
listener to give us
the specific language code.
So the way that we set it up, we
set it up as all the languages,
and then we pull
out a specific one.
Once we have that
language code coming in,
we'll send that to the
native text to speech APIs
on Android and iOS to
play that translated text,
as well as populate the
translated text field below.
Let's rerun the
app and try it out.
So Frank is going to come over.
And in our database, he's going
to simulate translating text
for us.
So we have a
translations reference,
he's going to add English
as the translation,
and say something
like hello world.
And if we're doing our
job here, hello world
pops up there and
on the other app,
and it would speak
to us as well.
- Hello world.
MIKE MCDONALD: There
you go, hello world.
So I'm done, right?
The app does exactly
what Frank wants, right?
He was standing there,
typing in the translations,
we could speak and he downloaded
and then typed them all out.
I don't know.
No?
OK, well, I'm done.
I heard Google has some really
cool machine learning stuff.
Did you guys see that in
the keynote yesterday?
Yeah?
So, Jenny.
Do you think you can
help us out here?
JEN TONG: You're not putting
me on the spot or anything,
are you?
I kind of like the idea of
Frank doing all the translations
by hand in the back.
No?
MIKE MCDONALD: I kind
of do too, honestly.
JEN TONG: OK.
OK, we'll actually write
some software to solve this.
But before we do that, could
we go back to the slides,
and I'll tell you a
little bit about what
we're going to build.
Step through the coding slides.
So yeah.
So we are going to be
using some software
to automate this part
of it, rather than have
Frank continue to code for us.
And we're going to do that in
the trendiest way possible,
because there's
probably a phrase you've
heard a few times during
this event so far,
which is machine learning.
Specifically-- well,
rather generally,
we could build this
up from scratch.
But unfortunately,
that's something
we're probably not going to be
able to do in the 20 minutes
we have left to write this app.
It takes a lot of time
to gather all the data
and train all the models
and get them all set up.
So we're going to take
a different approach.
We're going to use some of
those wonderful machine learning
backed APIs that are available
to solve a lot of problems.
And there's a huge
list of them that
are part of Cloud Platform
that you can make use of.
And we're going to use a
couple specific ones to fill
in the gaps that Mike
left in our application.
We're going to be
using the Cloud Speech
API to take the spoken word
from all the users of our apps
and convert that
into a transcription
and do a transcript, into text.
Then once we have
that text, we're
going to use the Cloud
Translation API to translate it
into the other languages so
the other users of the app
can hear it in
their chosen voice.
So we have a solution
there, right?
We have our app up there
running against Firebase.
We're using the database
for all the structured data.
We have our audio
files in storage.
And we have these cool Cloud
APIs to do the heavy lifting.
We're done, right?
Well, kind of.
There's one little line missing
from this diagram that kind of
messes it up a little bit,
which is how do we wire
all these things up together?
So if you were to come in
and solve this problem,
using knowledge you
might have had before you
came to this talk--
oh wait, sorry.
Taking a step back, there are
a few different challenges
that come up as our application
gets this additional level
of complexity.
And these are kind of an example
of larger problems that you
face as your mobile apps
get more complicated.
So one of these
challenges is secrets.
So when we're
building mobile apps,
sometimes we have some
secret information.
For example, if
you're writing a game,
you might have the
special code that
helps you detect
when people cheat,
because people always cheat at
mobile games for some reason.
Or if you're using
some Cloud APIs,
like Speech and Translate,
you might have some API keys
that you wouldn't want somebody
using for their own purposes.
And the truth is, if
you take this code
and you burn it into the
app and you release it,
somebody is going to find a way
to get that information out.
And then you'll be sad,
because your API key will be
out of quota and you'll be sad.
But there is a solution,
which is using the cloud.
We can take that information and
we can put it up into the cloud
and get it out of the hands
of our meddling users.
And we're going to take
that path this time.
Another challenge you
face is resources.
So mobile phones are
amazingly powerful today.
They're as powerful
as supercomputers
from only a few years ago.
But there's one thing about them
that has not scaled with that.
It is batteries.
So you can do all sorts of
heavy lifting on that phone.
But if the phone-- if your
user's battery is dead,
they're going to be
sad, and they will not
be using your app very much.
So when you have really
resource intensive stuff,
you can take that load and
push it up into the cloud,
and run it on more
powerful computers which
also have the luxury of being
plugged into mains electricity.
Then your users will be happy,
because their phones will still
have batteries.
And they'll continue to use
your app and everything will
be successful and happy.
One more, which is
especially relevant to us,
as I can see the little clock
ticking down, is code sharing.
So one really big pain for
building a mobile application,
especially if you want
to target a whole bunch
of different
platforms, is having
to rewrite the same
functionality over and over
and over again for
different platforms.
And this is a bummer.
And there are a lot of
different approaches to trying
to solve this problem.
But one approach to
solving this problem
is to put some of your
resource, some of your code,
some of your business
logic up in the cloud,
and then connecting to
all of your mobile devices
over an API.
Thereby only having to write
this logic once and share it
across all your
devices via that API.
So if you were to try
to solve this problem,
using maybe the
knowledge you had
before you came to
this talk, digging
into your traditional
bag of tricks,
you might come up with
a solution like this.
So we have our awesome
Firebase app running
on those mobile devices.
We'll just spin up
some compute nodes,
and maybe we'll write some APIs.
We'll make a Django server or
we'll do some Node.js stuff.
Then we'll stick
the keys in there
and use that to manage
all that stuff--
which is great.
It'll be great when
you get started.
But then as your application
gets more use and more
complexity, you're
going to find yourself
in a more complicated place.
You're going to find
yourself managing
all sorts of caches and firewall
rules and all sorts of stuff
like that.
But we don't really want
to deal with that today.
We want something fast and easy.
That's what this
talk is about, right?
Yeah.
And at Google, we've
been kind of helping
you take care of
your app management
woes for a long time.
We want you to spend
the time writing
the code for your
actual application
and spending less time
doing that other overhead.
One way I joke about it is, we
are code as a service hipsters.
Since 2008, when
App Engine launched,
you've been able to push
a web app to the cloud
and not have to worry
about scaling up or down,
or how the cache is
implemented, that kind of stuff.
And although App Engine is
still a wonderful solution
to a lot of problems, it's
not quite a perfect fit
for what we're
dealing with today.
We want something a
little bit different.
So that's why instead of
spitting up a bunch of servers
on compute or using
App Engine, we're
going to do something a
little bit different today.
We're going to use
Cloud functions.
Yay.
They are the perfect little
bit of application glue
to hold our
application together.
And they will allow us to
solve all of those problems I
mentioned before.
We're going to be
able to take our keys
and stuff them up
into those functions
to keep everything
running nice and great
and away from the prying hands
of our less friendly users.
It would also allow us to
take the more heavy lifting
our application has to do,
in terms of the translation,
and take that off of the device
and put it into the cloud.
And I could tell you more
about how this works.
But that's not what
you're here for.
You're here to see
some code, right?
So let's build it.
So [INAUDIBLE], switch
it over to code view.
Awesome.
So what we have
going on here is,
we have Frank, over here
on my right and your left,
writing some code
and cloud functions.
And we have the console
on the other side.
So you can see stuff
updating live in Firebase.
So one of the first things
you're going to notice
is different than the last
chunk of live coding we did is--
cloud functions don't need a
lot of stuff to get started.
Previously, we had a couple
of lines of boilerplate code,
because mobile applications
are just kind of like that.
But all we have for
cloud functions to get
started is some variables
up top, specifically
that specify some authentication
credentials for our cloud APIs,
and a function stub.
And that's all we really
need to get started.
So to get started,
what we're going to do
is we're going to
add another function.
And what this function
is going to do
is it is going to
trigger whenever there
is a write to the database.
And the first thing
it's going to do
is it's going to extract
some information from some
of the metadata, including the
language the user was speaking,
as well as some
information that's
dependent on the phone
platform, like the sample
rate and the encoding.
Which as it turns out is
different for each platform,
we discovered while
we were writing this.
So we're going to take that.
We're going to hang on to it.
And then we're going to
send that information up
to the Cloud Speech API
along with a reference
to the recorded file
from Firebase storage.
And this is actually
one of my favorite parts
of this implementation, as you
can see that we don't actually
have to download the bits and
bytes of that audio recording.
Because all this stuff
integrates really
well together, we can just
send over a reference,
which is nice and lightweight.
And then that API is just
going to slurp it down
from the same place that it
was stored by our mobile app.
And then once we get a response
back from the Cloud Speech API,
we're going to take
that, and we're
going to write it
back to the database.
And this actually
kind of completes
one whole lap on our app.
We now have the point where our
app can take in that recording
and convert it into a
transcript that we should
be able to see in the database.
So should we give it a spin?
Let's give it a spin.
MIKE MCDONALD: Hello world.
JEN TONG: And I think
there it is already.
Oh, that's the file uploading.
So we can see the
upload metadata.
So now everything
is going right.
The function is chugging away.
And in just a moment we will
see another node appear.
And it will be awesome.
Sometimes it takes a moment
for the first one to spin up.
We're going to try
from the backup phone.
Oh no, there it is.
We cannot blame the Wi-Fi.
Or maybe we can.
But there it is.
Hello world, in text,
in the database.
MIKE MCDONALD: Can I try?
JEN TONG: Can you try?
Of course you can try,
MIKE MCDONALD: Hello world.
JEN TONG: I promise we're
going to say something
different at some point.
Why?
JEN TONG: Why?
There are other things
people want to communicate.
MIKE MCDONALD: Oh, there it was.
Right there.
JEN TONG: Woo hoo.
[APPLAUSE]
But at this point, I've
only done about half
of what I promised I would do
when Mike handed me the baton.
We've now taken the text--
we've taken the
voice of the user
and we've converted into text.
But it's only in
there in one language,
the language that
user spoke it in,
which is not quite right at all.
It's just kind of like
a chat device now.
A communicator, we
want our communicator
to also have a
universal translator.
So we're going to
solve this problem
in the way you might expect,
by writing another function.
Yay.
So we're going to
go ahead and we're
going to add another function
in our cloud functions.
And this function is going to
trigger when that transcript is
written to the database.
And it's going to get the
transcript text itself, as well
as the language that the
speaker was speaking.
And then what it's
going to do is
it's going to iterate through
all of the different languages
that our app supports--
seven, in this case.
And for each one of
those, it is going
to send that transcript along
with the source language
to the Translation API.
And then as the responses come
back from the Translation API,
we're going to write those
back to a different node
in the database.
And then finally, once the last
translation has made it back,
whichever translation decides
to be the slacker that time,
we're going to signal to the
function that we are done.
And this is one of the
anti-climactic parts
of Firebase development.
Sometimes you have a
checklist of the five things
you know you need to do,
and then all of a sudden you
finish them, and you
realize that, hey, wait,
my application is
completely done now.
But I guess we should
verify that for sure.
Let's just give it a run.
MIKE MCDONALD: Hello world.
We're really unoriginal.
JEN TONG: There it goes.
We see the metadata
from the upload appear.
Another transcript.
- Hawaiians.
JEN TONG: Ah.
MIKE MCDONALD: Sorry about that.
JEN TONG: What language is
that in, that it talked?
MIKE MCDONALD: I said, hello.
Something about Hawaiians.
JEN TONG: OK.
It didn't quite get it.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN:
You said it in English,
you selected Japanese.
JEN TONG: Oh, this
is what happens
when you don't use it right.
It was user error.
Hawaiians, apparently,
is what happens
when you tell it you're
speaking Japanese
and you say hello world.
Today we learned something.
So I guess our application
is done, then, right?
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: Hold on.
Did we ever test it?
JEN TONG: We tested
the full cycle.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN:
Yeah, so clearly
if we say we speak Japanese, and
we say hello world in English,
it doesn't really work.
JEN TONG: OK.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: So we
probably should test it.
But I have a good idea
for that, I think.
JEN TONG: Oh, yeah.
This is what we learned.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: Let
me take this one, Jen.
Can we switch back to
slides for a moment?
This one.
So when you're done
writing your functions,
you deploy them with
a single command.
You run Firebase deploy
and it uploads your code
to Google Cloud, where it runs
in Google Cloud functions.
It's a single command, but
it takes a bit of time.
So we've prepared it
this time for you.
Now to be honest, I'll
admit that I came up
with that I wanted these apps.
But when we started
this project,
I was sort of skeptical.
Because I wasn't really sure
that we could build this,
these two apps, in 30 minutes.
And I'm watching the clock.
They did.
And that's actually
pretty amazing.
So--
[APPLAUSE]
But if you watch very
carefully, you'll
see that we actually did
slightly more than just two
apps.
There's a URL at the
bottom of the screen.
I'll make it a bit bigger.
So we built a third
app, a web version
of the same application.
And this is audio participation.
Audience participation, and
audio participation, actually.
So if you now go on your
phone or your laptop
to babelfire.cloud, I love
to use top-level domains.
You will see an app
very similar to ours.
It's a read-only version of that
same app, because to be honest,
I didn't want to open up
an audio channel to all 300
of you.
And so it's a read only
version of the same app.
You get a drop down box,
and you select the language.
And then you will
hear the last sentence
we said in the
language you select.
So right now, that is the
Japanese interpretation
of Mike saying hello world.
Fairly interesting.
I have the same Android
app installed on my phone.
So I'm going to start it.
And I wonder--
I was scanning for
familiar faces.
Who here understands Dutch?
So I see a few hands going up.
But actually that's
quite surprising,
because you might
not realize it,
but if you open
[INAUDIBLE] on your phone,
you understand Dutch.
And you might not
have noticed, but I
have a tiny bit of an
accent, because I'm not
a native English speaker.
I'm from the Netherlands,
and I speak Dutch.
So I have the app open, and
I'm going to say Nederlands.
And then I'm going
to say something,
and you will hear it in the
language that you selected.
You won't understand
a word of what I said,
but about five to 10
seconds later, you will.
[SPEAKING DUTCH]
I still hear a lot of Hawaiians,
so let's see how this works.
So my text is now being
uploaded to the cloud storage,
it's being transcribed
into Dutch text,
and is being translated
into the seven languages
that we have
available in the app.
Then it's being
sent to your phone.
- The application works
and you understand Dutch.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN:
Did that work?
[APPLAUSE]
Demos are scary.
But we're Firebase.
We like taking a challenge.
So we could still have
faked this one, right?
I sort of knew what
I was going to say.
So when you all were coming
in, we asked a few people
if they speak a language from
the seven that we had selected.
And I think there was
somebody on the first row that
speaks Hindi.
Is that correct?
Can you come up to the
stage for a moment?
We'll do it right here.
OK.
So we're going to do
a bit of a game here.
Are you game?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: Cool.
So I'm going to
select Hindi there.
Now I want you to
think of a short phrase
that you are going
to say to the app.
Now this is taking
a lot of risk,
because I don't understand
a word of Hindi.
OK.
Let's see.
That's this option, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: Ready.
COMPUTER VOICE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING HINDI]
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: Did
anyone understand that?
Because I sure didn't.
So one person there.
Was it friendly?
We can still unplug the audio.
Let's see what
Translate makes of this.
COMPUTER VOICE: You act
like you understand and.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: Is
that is what you said?
Otherwise we're
going to try again.
No?
OK.
Let's try again.
Once more.
No, it should be fine.
That is the correct one, right?
Let's try slightly louder, then.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING HINDI]
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: Fingers
crossed for this one.
It's uploading.
It's being
transcribed, translated
to all seven
languages, one of which
we've selected on the laptop.
COMPUTER VOICE:
Today is Thursday.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN: That
sounds a lot better.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
What do you know?
I do understand Hindi after all.
OK.
Let's take this home.
So I started off with
painting a picture
of how I want apps to look.
I want a universal
translation app
that I call babel fire
because I'm a geek.
And I said I wanted
two apps in 30 minutes.
Then Mike came on
stage and explained
how you would probably build
that app if you've never
used Firebase.
That's write the
application code,
write middleware, and then
interact with Google Cloud
Services from that middleware.
And Mike said, no, no, no, no.
There is a better way to do
this, because there's Firebase.
And with Firebase,
your application code
can communicate directly
with our powerful managed
backend services.
That means that we take
care of all the scalability
and security so
that you can focus
on building the functionality
that your users love.
And in this case, I'm the
user and I love translations.
So Mike wrote an app
that record an audio file
and write it to cloud storage
through the Firebase SDK.
And then he wrote metadata
about the audio file
into the Firebase database.
Then Jen came on stage.
And [INAUDIBLE]
cloud functions that
would be triggered
from the metadata
and would take the audio file
and send it to the Cloud Speech
API, and return the transcript
of the text that was spoken.
Then we write that
back into the database.
We have another
cloud function that
gets triggered that sends
the text to Cloud Translate
and translates it into
the seven languages
that we have
available in our app.
We get the translations
back, and we wrote them
into the database, where Mike
picked them up in the app
and spoke them on the device
with the text to speech.
This all in 30 minutes.
Sure, we did some prep work.
But to be honest,
I doubt there's
a lot of technologies
out there that
allow you to do that
much in this little time.
And this is Google.
So this has all been
built to Google scale.
That means that if
your app takes off,
and you suddenly
are indeed implanted
into every human in the
world, it will scale with you.
We also have a lot more APIs.
We just used two Cloud APIs.
There's 150 or more of those.
And this is one
of the things that
gets us excited about cloud
functions in combination
with Firebase, because
we just picked two APIs
and made a very cool
story out of it.
And you can pick other APIs and
build your own story out of it.
In fact, if you like
doing that, then I highly
recommend that you stay in
this room after our session.
Because we have Brendan
and Thomas coming up here.
They have an entire box full
of these snippets of codes.
And they're just going to
glue them together and build
beautiful stories out of them.
I highly recommend that
you stay around for that.
I definitely will.
OK, and with that, I think
we're ready to wrap up here.
So I really want to
thank you for being here
and building this
application with us.
If you have any
questions about Firebase,
come meet us in
the experts area,
which I think is downstairs,
if I remember correctly.
Or to be honest, find anyone
with a bright yellow shirt
with Firebase on it.
In fact, I see the two founders
of the company sitting there.
They will love to
answer your questions,
because there's-- to be honest--
nothing more that Firebasers
love more than interacting
with developers that use
our technology.
With that, I want to thank you.
And I look forward to
actually tethering to as many
of you as possible
during the rest of Next,
because I can't wait to
see what you build next.
[APPLAUSE]
Mike says we have
time for questions.
Anyone?
MIKE MCDONALD: Come
up to the microphones
if you have questions.
FRANK VAN PUFFELEN:
We scared them.
MIKE MCDONALD: Or come
up and talk to us.
We're OK with either.
[MUSIC PLAYING]